but but
have any of you cheated before
[Music]
no no be honest no no honestly no no
i've had an open relationship
where i'm allowed to see other people is
that you know yeah
okay
you guys spoke about it like you had a
conversation then
youtube no no no no we were we were
young we were young and
we couldn't really see each other so it
was like okay let's have an open
relationship but we had to tell the
other person if you'd like if you'd like
and you guys told each other everyone
i never told him and i fell in love with
somebody else
and this is why cheating is different
from men that's why but is that cheating
because she was in an open relationship
it wasn't technically cheating
but then i just
i was in love with two people at one
time which was really weird
and then i went with the other one which
which is fair because i feel like when
you're an open
open relationship in the back of your
head when you've agreed to that you have
like that you always acknowledge the
possibility
you can fall in
you said you love said that you said
this is me in my 20s right 21 22. yeah
this is the perfect time to do it um no
i'm kidding wait and so you didn't do
that at the olympics what are you doing
stupid take a hall pass if you make the
olympics guys
the village like everyone was just they
gave out free condoms like everyone's
just trying to [ __ ] everyone well it's a
lot of sexy people in one place and a
lot of male 1 testosterone and sexiness
in one spot i mean i'm not going down to
the shop at the end i might stick around
like gymnastics or like
like a little track and field
yeah i mean but even i feel obviously
shot put yeah but everyone's
somebody's trusting somebody's treasure
hundred pound a pound yeah
he's a lot of beholders there you go
make sure you that is actually a fact
like b isn't that either the whole
delight what you think is beautiful
because that's what i think is beautiful
of course the fact that you said you're
staying with someone that's 100 behind
you i don't think you understand 100
pound is like
but some people like but that's to you
that's not the guy you fell in love that
you knew like it's not but that's what
i'm saying people evolve like everyone
changes
into a [ __ ] yeah
so why can't i evolve to like that i
feel like she could yeah awesome do you
know okay go say it she could evolve to
like i can't evolve to like that what if
i do like see my likes and this is
changes like all the time like with diff
like the different people i date like it
they change for him you've changed like
you didn't like that at first now it's
like i love this guy so much i would
like starting like balloons like what's
wrong with that no that's just there's
nothing wrong with that it's just like
he's not healthy it's not real yeah like
like you're just like this is what girls
do and i think it's our natural instinct
because we want people to be like
included but like like come on body
positivity you're not going to be
attracted to this the guy the same 100
pounds that's just common
i don't know why as girls like we like
because you're smart yeah i know you
know that's not real like i know like
like in your life
make it make sense make it make sense
necessary yo they need your help right
now you can't even help me
on a dummy mission
don't be messing
reinforcements
is it weird to hear a girl say these
points yeah no because i'm not what her
point is i don't know mine oh yeah yeah
so i normally we're on the back end like
but you know what i never said that i
agreed with versailles was like we'll
leave but i thought i'd do the most to
make like to try
and like change that lifestyle right but
you're kind of switching what you said
yeah i just said to you i was like yo
you know it was ten years that deep and
they got fat and you're like yeah this
is what girls do too instead of saying
to everything that is
this
is where girls like we moved the goal
post and that's what you just what's
wrong with that well it's fine but like
like instead of just saying like like
that's what you did we moved the goal
post but i feel like